[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour la 15e fois en 5 ans le général de
Gaulle a rencontré le chancelier à de
Noël qu'il était venu accueillir à
l'aérodrome de Villacoublay les deux
hommes d'État ont passé le week-end au
Château de Rambouillet un week-end qui
devait être un week-end d'adieu puisque
le chancelier abandonne le gouvernement
de l'Allemagne fédérale mais les deux
artisans de la réconciliation
franco-allemande ont décidé de garder le
contact
[Musique]
les adieux beaucoup moins définitifs ont
été échangés entre parents et enfants à
l'école de Beneden près de Londres et on
pouvait voir notamment le roi Hussein de
Jordanie fait à ses dernières
recommandations à sa fille
mais la plus célèbre de ces jeunes
étudiantes était la princesse Anne que
sa mère était venue accompagnée la reine
Elizabeth avait tenu à conduire
elle-même sa fille au collège
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une première année de pensionnat pour
Anne dont l'éducation avait été faite
jusqu'à présent au palais de Buckingham
[Musique]
les grands couturiers ont prévu un hiver
rigoureux et les femmes seront
tambitouflées des pieds à la tête Lanvin
remplace les bannis d'un style très
montagnard da et culotte feront
d'ailleurs bon ménage
Gardin de son côté préconise les bottes
cuissardes montent en haut sous la jupe
ou bottes de dracause qui rajeunissent
la silhouette un petit chapeau de curé
complétera de sa note irrespectueuse
cette tenue estudiante
m fait de la botte un accessoire luxueux
il traite la fourrure par-dessus la
jambe nouer négligemment sous le menton
ces pointes de fourrure protégeront les
élégantes contre la bise et la neige
cette mode si excentrique soit-elle ne
restera pas l'apanage de la haute
couture
chaussettes et bottes courront les rues
dès les premiers frimas en même temps
que les casques dignes de Valentina la
cosmono
et il ne faudra pas s'étonner si l'on
voit quelques jeunes personnes se
promener dans cette tenue originale qui
tient à la fois du motard du facteur et
de l'égoutier
[Musique]
par un été qui fut un été pourri un
certain confort vestimentaire n'a pas
manqué d'être apprécié par les chanteurs
de l'équipe nerlandaise au moment
d'affronter les embruns de la mer du
Nord pour rallier la station belge de
Knokke-le-Zoute
venue de Hollande de France d'Italie
d'Angleterre d'Allemagne et de Belgique
les chanteurs européens avaient
rendez-vous dans la station belge pour y
discuter la cinquième Coupe d'Europe du
tour de chant une coupe que devait
enlever la française Jacqueline Dano
surnommée la tragédienne de la chanson
[Musique]
je n'ai vraiment
plus rien à faire
je l'aime vraiment
[Musique]
plus rien
[Applaudissements]
la coquette Maurice Chevalier recevait
ses nombreux amis pour fêter à la fois
la Saint Maurice c'est 75 ans et sa
prochaine rentrée parisienne il est bien
vrai que celui qui créa voici quelques
lustres ménilmontins Valentine ou
prospère est apparu plus jeune que
jamais à tous ceux qui étaient venus le
féliciter dans rivarna Apple Derval
[Musique]
de Jean Rigaud à Henry
aussi n'est-ce pas seulement le passé
qu'on a évoqué à la look et tandis que
Maurice Chevalier soufflait les 75
bougies de son gâteau d'anniversaire on
ne songeait qu'à l'avenir
[Musique]
aux musical aussi les croulans se
portent bien
[Musique]
Notre Dame de Fourvière que se
dérouleront les Jeux Olympiques de 1968
lion qui vient de célébrer son
millénaire et où l'on peut encore goûter
le charme de vieilles rues d'un autre
âge ambitionne d'être dans cinq ans
ville olympique le gouvernement a retenu
sa candidature pourquoi Lyon c'est que
cette ville en pleine expansion sur tous
les plans a des titres particuliers à
faire valoir tout d'abord son axe
routier nord-sud qui permet de traverser
la ville en un temps record et qui offre
une capacité de circulation qui à peu
près toutes les villes de France peuvent
lui envier
et puis surtout Lyon possède déjà des
installations sportives de classe
olympique
le long du Rhône on achève un ensemble
nautiques qui contiendra 4 bassins
par ailleurs la cité de la soie dont le
nombre des piscines est passé depuis
1958 de 2 à 5 possède déjà une piscine
olympique
[Musique]
mais le plus beau fleuron à la couronne
sportive de Lyon c'est le Palais des
Sports qui a déjà cette année abrité
nombre de rencontres internationales
modernes vaste on serait tenté de dire
luxueux il peut contenir 15000
spectateurs
il n'est pas jusqu'au théâtre antique
qui ne puisse avoir sa place dans le
déroulement des jeux et qui est destiné
à servir de cadres disciplines
gréco-romaine voilà pourquoi la
candidature de Lyon peut être retenue
pour le grand rassemblement olympique de
[Musique]
ah non des Jeux Olympiques de Tokyo
l'athlétisme français progresse à patte
géant les athlètes russes en savent
quelque chose désormais le 100 mètres du
match France - Russie une merveilleuse
promenade du français pickman 3/10 une
série science olympique pour pig mal qui
ne s'arrêtera pas en si bon chemin
le 200 m c'est la répétition exacte du
100 m
âle toujours lui s'envole vers une
nouvelle victoire mais cette fois
Josselin Delecourt devant ce soviétique
Haute-Saône pour la deuxième place
d'ailleurs presque toutes les courses
sans favorables aux Français
[Applaudissements]
en revanche dans les concours les coloss
russes ne laissent aucune chance à leurs
adversaires kusenens of donne l'exemple
en remportant le javelot
[Musique]
le 1500 mètres on attendait avec
impatience à cause de Michel JAZY sa
cheville allait-elle tenir j'assis
rapidement rassure tout le monde mais le
soviétique caroloff tient absolument à
jouer les 3e larron et cela par tous les
moyens il joue des coups dans le virage
on prend un moment que Badoo et même
jasis soit décroché et bien non les deux
Français se dégagent
et cela c'est l'illustration de la
volonté de vaincre de tous les athlètes
au cours de cette rencontre la plus
belle à laquelle est assistée les
Parisiens depuis de nombreuses années
ce match personne ne l'oubliera pas plus
que l'exhibition de Valérie Brunel le
Sputnik comme on l'appelle à Moscou il
franchit deux mètres 17 comme s'il était
à l'entraînement
[Applaudissements]
Bernard et Turine ont pratiqué la guerre
d'usure à deux reprises différentes sur
le 5000 et sur le 10000 M Fiori n'était
le plus fort il a gagné les deux courses
Bernard n'a pas à rougir Turing sera
peut-être champion olympique à Tokyo sur
l'une de ces deux distances
enfin victoire française dans les relais
le 4 x 400 qui lui donne le match nul in
extremis et le 4 x 100 que nous voyons
ici départ éclair de Lambron qui prend
l'avantage mais qui gâche tout en
passant le témoin à Genevet le rustère
vanessiane lama tout faire de l'équipe
qui ajoute une belle pointe de vitesse à
son record du monde du saut à longueur
reprend le chemin perdu mais il y a
pYGMA
et avec lui la balance penche
définitivement du côté français
[Musique]
avec vélocité une victoire dont personne
ne doutait
finalement match nul 106 à 106 entre
deux grandes équipes d'athlétisme qui
fraternisent après une rencontre qui a
enthousiasmé tous les spectateurs de
colon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]